it's it's a world where just anything is
possible and just whatever is in your
imagination can can happen and so that I
mean there's a ways of expressing I
think it's a healthier way of maybe
getting things out you know rather than
punching somebody in the face or
something you can I can play it on my
guitar and it doesn't hurt anybody in it
you can say what you need to say and I
can see nothing but good comes from
music so for me it's just a bit up in a
way I feel like it's it's my like now as
I'm struggling to find words to express
myself when I play music I feel like
that's where my real voice is or that's
where I really say something more than
with words I mean words are words are
cool too but I'm not that good
I think if there's a natural way I have
a speaking I hesitate and I think and I
it takes me a while to get the thoughts
formed in my mind and to get them to
come out and the same thing happens when
I'm playing music there's I'm thinking
and there's I'll hesitate or all so
there's a natural rhythm that I have
that happens when I play but then also I
mean you can't just the the silence is
as important as the you know there's
dark and light and you can't see one or
the other if you know they cancel each
other out so I mean if there's sound
there has to be no sound to go with it
before it'll mean anything I think
I guess I don't really think so much
about what it's called although it's
just music or but there was a time when
I shied away from calling myself a jazz
musician but or maybe it was because I
don't like to be boxed in somehow but
but these days I for me
jazz it when I started to find out about
jazz music for me that it that was a
place where anything was possible the
people that I listened to when I started
to hear Sonny Rollins and Thelonious
Monk and Charlie Parker and there was
something that those guys were doing
that it seemed to include it what it
wasn't exclusive I don't know if I don't
think they were thinking about the name
you know dude gallant in ER but there
was something in their music that it
wasn't exclusive it included everything
that they knew there that all of their
experience and in that way I still think
of myself as a just I mean it's just I
take what I know or where I've been and
just try to make something out of it and
and that's what I think jazz to me means
so I don't mind being called a jazz
musician
I'm not sure the it's the improvisation
and the composition it's also it's
getting more and more it's it's harder
to separate the two I mean sometimes I
used to say that when I would write like
when I write music it's sort of a slowed
down version of when I improvise or
something it's it's like you have more
time to be critical or block yourself
you know you're and when you're
improvising you have to just deal with
the moment and but I think I'm the two
things are getting closer together where
when I'm writing music on paper it's I'm
able to maybe not judge it so much in
the moment and just let it let it come
out and and then at the same time when
I'm improvising spontaneously I'm I'm
getting closer to having it be maybe the
structure of it being more solid or
something I don't know
and I mean even if I play the same same
notes or the same song or and with the
there's so many things that are
happening with the the people that I'm
with playing and the the sound of the
room and the audience and the
temperature and whatever other noises
going on or what happened that day or
there's no way you can play the same
thing twice even if you're trying to I
mean I'm trying to actually not play it
the same way twice I guess but
so I mean in that way even playing a set
piece for me it doesn't feel that much
different than something that's
improvised
it used to be seemed like it would be
easier for me to do it when I was
traveling or anywhere I would just write
stuff down and but now I need more
solitary concentrated time and I'll I'll
write a lot like I actually had a little
bit of time off recently where I just
wrote music every day without I didn't
have any deadlines or it wasn't for any
reason other than just doing it and then
I was able to get into a real rhythm of
it's it's almost like I don't know what
I seems for me it works best if I don't
judge what I'm doing as I'm doing it or
every time I start to think about what
it actually is then I become too
critical and it just stops the process
so I have to just it's like just I sort
of get into a the energy of it and the
stuff just comes out and pages and pages
of this stuff I filled up a few
notebooks with music over a few weeks
recently and then the process then I go
back and I start looking at it more
critically and sometimes there's
fully-formed things there or there's
just germs of things that can become
something bigger and then I'll bring it
I've been so lucky with I'm just so
fortunate with the people that I play
with over the last I don't know well
since I started trying to do my own
music I've been I feel really lucky that
I've been around people that have backed
me up
encouraged me and so much of what I
write it almost doesn't feel it so much
of it comes from the people I'm with
when I bring them a melody and they put
stuff into it that I could never you
can't really write it down so with the
different groups I have I usually
present them with some kind of structure
like just maybe it's just one melody or
maybe it's a more fully formed four-part
thing or something but there's a point
where I just kind of leave it up to them
to do with it what they want and that's
really exciting for me is it it's not
like just writing music and bringing it
to some anonymous people and just having
them play exactly what's there it's
there's more going on than that
when I start listening to Miles Davis
playing the trumpet or or Bill Evans
playing the piano like I'd hear the
piano I think oh he's you know they can
play notes in one hand and the notes
just ring out and then they can play
other notes and so that led me to get a
delay pedal where I could play something
and then the notes would keep going and
then I could play some other stuff I
mean it that came from really from
thinking about piano and or or even a
distortion
I remember hearing I was hearing like
Miles Davis playing a trumpet and then I
heard Carlos Santana playing the guitar
and he had this really you know he was
pushing the amp way past what was the
normal or what was you know he was
really getting this distorted long or
Jimi Hendrix did that but I started to
hear wait a minute that sounds kind of
like the trumpet and so then I got a
distortion thing I said so I mean it
kind of came almost more from trying to
mimic these other instruments than
although I did you know of course I
listened to Jimi Hendrix and I listened
to Santana too but but a lot of that
stuff it's just something I'm trying to
realize that I'm hearing in my head